uh on behalf of uh hillary and adventure
37 i'd like to welcome everyone to uh
the second part of our webinar webinar
series this one on one health the
critical crossroads of animal human and
environmental environment health how do
we really scale up one health my name's
michael victor i'm the head of
communications and knowledge management
at uh at dillary uh and just wanted to
mention that this is the second in the
series the first one
i was focused on uh
uh was focused on leveraging livestock
to combat malnutrition and i did put the
link to the webinar in the
chat so you can view it there so just as
we get started it'd be great to if
everyone could put their full name and
organization uh on their name so you
just
go to your name
click on more and you can then uh click
on rename so you should be able to
rename and put your full name and your
organization helps everyone identify who
is here you can also add your country if
you want
uh we will be enabling uh closed
captioning which seems to help a little
bit but there's always often mistakes so
but it does sometimes help
remember to keep your microphones off
when not speaking i think most of the
people we we have is a webinar so you
won't have to worry about that
uh
if you can't see or hear uh please close
and restart the zoom sometimes things
get stuck
again we we are going to be using the
chat a lot so it'd be great if everybody
could uh post questions or comments into
the chat we'll have a moderator who will
be able to feed questions uh to the
panel when we have that and if you have
questions to each of the speakers please
put them into the chat and they can
answer directly uh during the webinar uh
and just remember that the session is
recorded
uh and any private chats are often also
off often visible to us as well we will
also be uh live tweeting uh so please uh
you know please recognize that and we'll
we'll be uh tweeting so you can also
tweet i use the hashtag please why
livestock matter
which helps a lot maybe susan can put
that into the chat okay great so with
that i'd like to introduce mark mitchell
to uh to kick us off and take us through
the rest of the webinars thanks a lot
and over to you mark all right thank you
michael and i'm mark mitchell i'm the
director of livestock and dairy
activities with venture 37 and we're
going to set the context for today's
discussion with this short film it
concerns land use policies
um and how at times they can be
unacquainted unintended consequences
often at the expense of the ecosystems
this video is on the privatization of
land and around the uh mara serengeti in
kenya in tanzania and demonstrates how
diseases can spread when
wildlife livestock and humans
cross over into each other's spaces
it's an integrated approach and we
take it away please
foreign
[Music]
in kenya is a classic example of what
happens when landscape policies are
developed without a one-held approach
this is because one health supports
integrated management of landscapes that
enhance sustainable coexistence of
agriculture and wildlife
many experts such as ecologists vets
public health professionals and others
need to be involved in government and
private sector decision making and
planning processes
this is
um
is
[Music]
nokia
the choices we make about ecosystems
have important consequences
sometimes unintended ones on human and
animal health
a one health approach helps reduce
further destruction and fragmentation of
wild habitats
incorporating biodiversity values while
at the same time considering the health
and nutrition needs of people
[Music]
okay thank you now i'd like to introduce
uh christina rossell she's a scientist
in the animal and human health program
at illary christina holds a diploma of
veterinary medicine and a phd in
biomedical sciences
she has led a number of projects on one
health and now leads a new hillary-led
bmz investment on improving animal and
human health in uganda
and helps conceptualize the bmz funded
hillary one health center for africa
which we'll hear about more in our panel
discussion
her particular interests include
research on the epidemiology of diseases
in the interface of livestock wildlife
and human health
parasitology working with students well
in the north south and the south south
technology
and the knowledge transfer
and we welcome you here today christina
thank you thank you for the introduction
and
uh
sorry to everyone who expected delia
here today i am stepping in for her
today
and um
yes i want to talk about the role of
livestock research at the one health
interface today uh just to set the scene
for the following panelists
and um coming from hillary of course our
core business is livestock research and
we are working based on a number of
opportunities and challenges that have
been identified over the years and one
of the biggest challenges probably
how to feed the global population in the
future um because population growth is
one of the biggest issues pressuring um
our planet and
we see that there's big disparity
between
current meat or animal source food
consumption between high income and low
and middle income countries and a
majority of the population growth will
happen in the global south in the future
that's also where a lot of the potential
is for growth of the sector for
opportunities to reduce poverty um
increase equity and livelihoods however
all these things come with a lot of
challenges
and not only at a local level but also
regional and global level
that is of course the emergence of
zoonotic diseases we know that more than
two-thirds of the pathogens they
originate in in animals and at some
point in time um have a spillover event
to humans
also uh increased livestock production
comes with an increase of
ox antimicrobials
or the livestock healthy which comes
with a lot of pressure on the
environment and
microbes and increasing the risk for
antimicrobial resistance
more livestock also means more methane
contributing to greenhouse gas emissions
and of course global warming which needs
to be
limited and of course the more mammals
for food or for eating that food to live
on this planet
the more we have environmental pollution
land and water degradation which again
increases um the risk for spillover
so
some of the key one health elements um
that we focus on are to be prepared to
detect and to respond and all of them
just like in the one health venn diagram
where all these
three different circles uh overlap also
these three components preparedness
detection and response they also overlap
and they cannot see independently and
i'll give a few examples today and i
think the following speakers they will
then go more into the details and give
more examples from their work
so
to be prepared we need to know where to
put our money uh that's always a a big
question by investors
we want to solve all problems at the
same time we don't know where to target
investments
often we come too late and try and solve
problems when they're already there so
data is one of the biggest issues we
face in the global south
we don't have data to prioritize we
don't have data for surveillance and
monitoring and therefore we also lack
data to target our interventions and
limited resources so that is one of the
major contributions that um livestock
research can make
on top of that
we have to utilize what we have and that
is a lot of local capacity we don't have
to take
interventions that have worked in the
north and implement them in the south
and expect the same results
we have to utilize local knowledge
we have to localize you uh yeah local
resources
local capacity and try and build this
capacity improve this capacity instead
of trying to reinvent the wheel and i
think bernard will talk more about this
later and by being um prepared and
investing early enough in data
generation and building local capacity
we can actually save a lot of money as
these two examples show investment in
yellow
in the um
[Music]
in the right figure investment in
keeping poultry uh vaccinating poultry
uh against avian influenza can really
reduce the economic
burden on
on affected countries
the second component is detection
and that's where biomedical sciences
come in of course but also social
sciences and of course we need to
understand these different zoonotic
pathogens
we need to understand where they come
from where they live how they survive in
the environment
is it mosquitoes is it waters is it
wildlife reservoirs is it livestock
reservoirs we need to understand the
process from infection
uh of humans uh and animals uh to the
host immune response so we can also be
able to develop diagnostic tools and
vaccines and then we need to consolidate
all this information that we have and
develop strategies to target those and
one example is shown here on the right
that work is
mostly generated by bernard and tim
we look at data on rift valley fever we
do entomological studies we know animal
reservoirs for rift valley fever we know
precipitation patterns
we know uh altitudes we have all this
data it's out there and we're trying to
fill data gaps with our field surveys
but then this data needs to be
consolidated so that decision makers
know okay we have a vaccine for
livestock let's go to the high risk
areas and these are the ones in red and
we need this for many of the health
subjects
and this is a good transition to the
response
and
the response is not just about having a
vaccine ready it's also about getting to
the vaccine to those people who need it
and kovid is one of these examples in a
in a global effort
and
miracle we have a vaccine already
but in east africa and other parts of
africa and southeast asia many people
have not yet benefited from the vaccine
it's very difficult to get it to people
to have people accept the vaccine to
have access to it governments are
struggling with buying vaccines and
therefore yeah the vaccine is not
available and which leads again to a
global problem of not having hurt
immunity through vaccination
kovit is just one example this happens
with a number of the health
interventions we are researching
so
these
components acceptability accessibility
affordability availability and
incentives are quite crucial in getting
interventions or research into use and
that is also just as the way we're
trying to generate data getting
interventions out
requires participation by uh the end
users communities and i guess we'll hear
a bit more about this about rangeland
land management in a bit
and finally i wanted to uh
highlight again two of the recent
publications that
give very constructive advice to
investors on
where to invest
what research gaps do we still have
where are the data needs and how we can
intervene in preventing not only the
next pandemic but also preventing other
uh
health
problems at the human animal environment
interface these are also the neglected
zoonotic diseases such as tapeworms
brucellosis
sleeping sickness
diseases that usually affect low and
middle income countries
we also have a silent pandemic
antimicrobial resistance so we're not
just talking about the big scares um we
give um
yeah an investment advice for challenged
these major anthropogenic drivers of
synonyms
so
this is my little
presentation to set the scene and now to
i can take questions if that is in the
agenda mark and otherwise i'll hand back
to you
all right thank you ma'am
we're gonna switch quickly to um uh
let's see bernard and i'm gonna skip
through this quickly so that bernard
gains a little time back and if you are
ready to go bernard you can start
talking to us about the policy
process and the scaling out at your
level thank you thanks mark my name is
bernard beth i work with hillary as a
senior scientist currently heading
the one health center which christina
[Music]
mentioned so um i'm presenting this for
focusing on how we are planning to scale
up scale out one health
practices and policies in sub-saharan
africa and i'm working with a big team
of people including leon christina
ashley
delia and hung
this is a project which is funded
currently by bmz
so let's go to the next slide
yes so this is first of all to to
clarify or to set up the terminologies
that we are using
when we talk about scaling we really
mean an ambitious process to expand the
coverage of one health
either through institute
institutionalization that's making sure
that policy makers
right at the national subnational levels
are able to apply one health
principles but also there's a component
on horizontal expansion this is
involving many other players
within the same levels of
application
but in the process of scaling up we are
not just thinking of
spreading out we only thinking of
refining
these institutions these practices
realizing that you know we are not
really here
to start off from the beginning but many
other players have
originally set up
platforms
and and and processes much earlier so
we're just helping to improve on the
quality
the main uh issue though is to really
identify what's that scalable units
because we know one health is quite
proud we really need to identify what's
the key component of one health that can
be scaled so let's go to the next slide
and i give examples of vertical scaling
and this again that's what i meant
institutionalization
and currently we are looking at the
platforms which were developed by
countries
regional economic blocks the tripartite
and many other players in the region and
trying to ask ourselves
what are the competencies how are these
platforms working so we are using an
evaluation tool that's called network
for evaluation of one health which is
classical
published and it's being used in many
places
to identify those gaps in planning
thinking working sharing
one health activities
and the main aim here is to identify
what which areas can we specifically
implement interventions to make these
platforms work much more
effectively
the second issue though would be
research for development and this is
where we're thinking of
we want to demonstrate how new evidence
can be used to inform
decision making but also to inform
networking partnerships
so that it can really come out so
clearly on which areas would those
partnerships work better for disease
control
so on the next slide i give a small
example on
horizontal
scaling
what we do here is basically about
building graduate fellowship programs so
that we can get more leaders more
students
more technical expertise
being used in the region
and it involves training students within
here at hillary but also helping local
universities in developing new curricula
uh on one health
through our research partnerships also
with governments ngos private sectors
we hope that in the process of us
implementing research with them
those
one health competencies come out
strongly and they get recognized as ways
of doing business
but lastly also is we are really
launching community outreach activities
which aim to build um
capacities at the local levels but also
there's a frontline staff here including
you know community based animal health
workers or community health volunteers
who work in the public public health
sector so all those people are brought
on board
to work together in the local levels
i think i have the second last slide
which
talks about the opportunities that we
have to build all these um activities
and one of them is um
they say huge interests locally on
building one health platforms and i
think that interest would really help us
to to move on from there there's also
one health platforms which have been
developed as i said earlier on and
there's a huge um skilled manpower in
mainstream government departments which
can be brought on board
in building all these initiatives but of
course as you know there are many
challenges and main the main one of
course is being funding levels are low
the other thing is
conceptualization of one health you know
one health is quite broad and many
people may not really define what we
mean by a scalable unit
that needs to be determined for us to
know where we begin from and where we
reach in terms of taking it forward uh
the the one thing that i also find it
very useful is to identify
reliable tools for assessment you know
we keep doing
there are many tools which are being
used currently for assessing scaling in
many interventions in veterinary even
public health but those ones have not
really been fine-tuned to capture one
health and those are the limitations
that we still face up to now
lastly of course one health as we know
it
is very much on prevention of diseases
of course it can be used for management
of diseases but most of the time we want
to use them for prevention
but we know communities and many people
in the on the ground
are really very much tailored towards
using curative services and not prevent
preventive services and that's this this
need for a mind mind
changing mindset in terms of how those
services are used
so i think i have only the two slides
one is on acknowledging partners and we
have many partners in this region
but the last one which i want to
emphasize is
we have had huge support from
a cgir research program called fonh
which was led by ifpri for the last 10
years they have been helping us to do
one health and it's coming to an end
in december this year so very much
like to acknowledge the support that we
have gotten from them
so thanks mark that's the end of my
presentation
okay thank you bernard uh we're gonna
quickly switch over to
uh a usda-funded project and hear from
uh lasha and the situation they're
facing in georgia please lasha
thank you mark
greetings
let me present safety and quality
investment livestock or simply skill
activities under the one health
principles
skillfully project is financed by the
usda is and implemented by the orlando
lakes venture 37 in georgia with our
local partner georgian farmers
association
following farm to four principles
project times to to
food safety and quality improvement
increase productivity and trade within
the georgian dairy and beef market
systems value chain next slide please
as i mentioned scale major task is to
support market systems development so i
would like to focus on how the skill
operates in the
strengthening one health approach in a
market systems development context
system includes
value interests starting from the input
suppliers farmers processors
distributors all the way to the finance
consumers
but also on top of it the market systems
donated we say we have a
role to develop supporting functions
such as strengthening education centers
sectoral trainers service providers etc
and let me give example here recently
skill trained call center operators of
the ministry of environmental protection
and agriculture of georgia
in animal health and food safety matters
and was first for them ever such
technical training
on the other hand we try to strengthen
local rules and regulations through
capacity building of the related state
authorities developing market led safety
quality
systems and mediating public private
partnership
as an additional example we conducted
the workshop regarding newly adopted
regulation and
animal byproducts
their use and disposal next slide please
so what are their tools in a toolbox
as
knowledge and awareness of the local
sector actors was identified as one of
the biggest challenges we uh conducted
set of the trainings in different wild
house related topics and let me give you
some examples from this list
food safety and hygiene principles that
included hazop system for deity and
preprocessors
we also trained all state and private
slaughterhouse veterinarians in meet
inspection
and as you see on the right in the
pictures the environment of the
trainings varies from the actual
practice in the processing plant
or more in kind of community based
interactions next slide please
also we
tried to to
cover gaps of
developing education materials
such as for our case manuals and
booklets and guidebooks
for that
activity we had a small motivator like
120 nanometers small motivator it's
basically all kind of people large
gatherings is still restricted for more
than a year now so we have to adapt
materials will print in the distributed
through our partners as well as
electronic versions are uploaded in the
local farmer's platform
one our
partners let's say
was the national food agency and they
disseminated these manuals to cattle
farmers through their state animal
vaccination campaigns
and here on the right you can see
example of one of our education
materials regarding veterinary medicine
products which explains the the health
one health and general health principles
as well as veterinary medicines residues
flow from animals to humans to
environment
this manual also contains the
information regarding antimicrobial
resistance but one more like a simple
farmer's understandable language
next slide please and here i have a list
of the other materials
as you can see in the content of them
and i would highlight
practical manuals for the slaughterhouse
veterinarians how to protect farm from
the chronic disease as well as manual a
vector board disease prevention is also
ending
next place slide please
in order to promote those education
materials skill developed animated
videos that you can see this videos are
simple way reflecting the key messages
of the education materials
these videos were designated through the
social media and popular original
televisions
and i believe that strength of this
concept was to provide the awareness
regarding the main highlights of that
very subject
but also at the same time aware target
groups regarding existence of these very
materials to be either downloaded from
the web platform or gained through their
skill
partners
so with this approach we are able to
educate target beneficiaries through the
combined method of the
videos plus manuals
that
do not actually require the gathering of
other people and it's also a
cost-effective
as a challenge that we identified in a
process access of the electronic
platform by the farmers is quite limited
but on the other hand on the opportunity
side we think and we're planning to
translate those education materials into
english which are currently georgian to
share amongst other venture 37 projects
next slide please
and basically that's
the final slide so we try to adopt to
the to the existing uh pandemic
situation by
uh providing and disseminating knowledge
regarding one health principles and
related actions in livestock sector
market systems and that's the way it is
thank you very much
okay thank you elisha
and the last of our speed talks here it
will come from madessa and the hillary
hill program
if you could uh please start that
discussion
uh my name is badass i work for
international lifestyle research
institute i'm regular scientist the
topic i'm going to talk on is linking
green line management to one health in
utopia
rangeland is important for one health
because this rangeland is a vast
land area that cover the world service
and also it is support millions of
people's pastoralists who are depending
on the rangeland rating of livestock
production and also it is good for
ecosystem service functioning when
so that one health
brings these three components by
including rangeland health to improve
the livelihood and ecosystem service for
the company who are living there
[Music]
one of the project which is integrating
the environmental aspect is heat
this project is uh actually the constant
rule led by vcfsu's along with ccm and
italy as with the objective of to
enhance the vulnerable community
to have a sustainable
well being
that the project is conducted in three
and three countries topia kenya somalia
with an approach of
bringing three these three components
animal human environmentalists to have a
good delivery service of one health
service at the ground level for the
pastoralist and this project also
engaged different community levels
including women men to have
to accommodate their need that
that to have a one health service
delivery and also to have a cost
effective approach for this this one
service delivery and doesn't it at the
end of the day this should be a model or
a solution of still silver and silver
service delivery
that should be recognized by different
tokens like a policy maker for the
pastoralist as a whole
most of the initiative of one health is
lacking this environmental health so
he'll make unique because of including
this one health
environmental health through an approach
of past battery range land management
this perspective land management have
three stage
and a different
state of
different steps so this actually a
process
that
maintains the community management plan
and improving uh the institution of this
community
rangeland management regulated
management
from this
uh
from rangeland there is a livestock
disease distribution and also there are
different regular conditions
so the disease and the regular condition
are highly integrated or correlated they
are functioning together so this prm is
bringing into the process of animal
disease to be integrated well from for
example if we take from our
one side or download land which is found
in moya red street
how one health and the grazings are
really linked together show us movement
through concentration of livestock and
high degradation of rangeland shows us
our wine health and grazing are
integrated
from this
institutional role
to bring to bring together a different
institution which are
to act for one health center
to learn from each other he developed
msip for stakeholders to discuss
learning
because of
environmental health is a broader so
that to understand what rangeland health
mean so msrb is a muslim style
stakeholder innovation platform where
many stakeholders are really from each
other or to avoid the challenges of not
understanding the
whole environment from this rangeland
heritage so the service delivery is to
improve the rangeland which are highly
degraded or to minimize to
maintain the rangeland size as it is so
to have an educated posture
as a sum up randyland health is a key
improving
the whole system of the ecosystem and
the productivity of
the whole area that improve the
livelihood and the
community as well so that bringing of
animal human
rangeland health is a good
to link to regular management to have a
wider impact of
the livelihood of communities so thank
you
if you have questions welcome
thank you
vadessa
um
we've now heard from
three different programs
and how they are scaling one health in
policy
uh training
public and private sector activities
and environmental pathways
and we're going to change over to some
questions now and i'd like to lead off
by asking bernard
how they've been able to reconcile the
differing interests between their
stakeholder holders
we naturally find that there's a little
bit of difference between what donors
want what local governments want and
what livestock owners want and i'd like
to hear your views on this process
thanks
mark for that question so
um yes you are right i mean most of the
donors or most of the development
agencies
usually fund
those
challenges or those those issues which
address epidemics pandemics with
international concern usually they look
at
risks which transcend countries and and
and regions
but we we find that
the stakeholders of the the people we
deal with at the community level
are very much interested in managing
day-to-day challenges in terms of
endemic diseases
or things which we call production
which may not really attract external
interest
so but i think there is a win-win um
there's a room for win-win situation
there because
the support we get from external
development partners which address
pandemics and epidemics can still help
in building
universal surveillance systems or build
capacity
which might be used to manage multiple
challenges at the same time
so in that way i think
you can still find a common ground
where
that external support
can still
be used to build capacity events to
manage local problems
thank you sir um last time i'm going to
turn to you next to kind of follow the
order of the speakers there
and what curious how you're building
capacity at the farm level to prevent
the spread of zoodonic disease what what
are producers the livestock owners
knowledge and awareness of one health
challenges how are they facing this
well mark
as i mentioned during my presentation uh
one of the skill developed education
material was
manual for main chronic diseases of
cattle
and for georgia that would be resilience
tuberculosis and glucoses
so we developed a manual that contains
the practical examples of the clinical
science disease prevention also
diagnostic practices
manual also explains kind of existing
regulations and also explains that this
is very important the primary actions to
be taken in case of the disease
suspicious before even the
veterinarian's engagement
also we put like sticky posters of the
disease clinical science
and also k messages that uh are attached
to the manual and these um owners of the
farms that that have been
delivered could stick them on the walls
or the employees hang around
so they will have always the major
information in front of them the
abortion and other clinical science and
also highlight and also clinical science
in humans as well so they would you know
understand that they might be exposed
so in my opinion that's the practical
example how to aware kind of farmers on
one health issues and try to get them on
our las
thank you
and bethesda
we're looking at the environmental part
of our tripartite and and we diagram one
health
why is it is it challenging to
incorporate one health into the
environmental issues
thank you mark uh
yes it is uh
if you see many of the
finance initiatives the environmental
health is lacking
uh it is neglected
many initiative this may may be because
of this environmental research
list
funding to have
to integrate this and also it is not
taken as like
seriously as uh other discipline like
medical and also even through the
issue
and
there also this environmental ha also
have different theories uh which is not
contextual to different uh areas like if
you take a series of indigenous
pastoralists
which is sometimes
they are
conflict each other
in some areas so that this is the main
point why
environment is not as
others
okay thank you for that interesting bit
of information
you know we we've labeled this as a hard
talk session and so the hardest question
i'm gonna pose back to uh christina
where she she led us off today
and as a thought leader in this field
where does the focus on one health and
livestock provide the greatest impact um
well
there's not a silver bullet answer to
that because the context of any health
problem is different in each country
right so i
i think uh
the focus should be on um
yeah the local context actually in which
the the animal diseases um yeah navigate
and the pathogens navigate and that
the reason why i'm saying this in
southeast asia for example where you
have a much higher pig population
you know
pigs as a livestock species would be of
much of more importance than um cattle
and small ruminants in east africa for
example
and maybe i would like to pass this on
to to my colleague bernard
who is more of a
a local leader in one health
than i am thanks
uh
sure bernard if you would like to follow
up please
no i think christina managed to dwell by
saying you know it change it it varies
from one place to another maybe what one
thing that jumped into mind because i
can see in your question is uh there's a
labeling of livestock
and since we are thinking of one health
you know livestock usually is considered
to be
and resourced in many places
and so
i guess bringing in one health
in that perspective might actually help
to enhance service delivery not just
looking at
disease per se but also managing
multiple
facets of livestock service delivery
in this region for example you know
many many remote locations
there's a big challenge on that and so i
see one health can really help us to
reach into the
those people who are considered to be
left behind by previous interventions
okay thank you
we we have
a couple of extra minutes is uh there
are specific questions from the chat box
that anyone would like to draw my
attention to
um
otherwise i'm gonna jump to one of our
other questions here what i'd like to
ask is each of you just quickly to give
me um a quick answer to say
if
which
part of one health
changes or the program implementation
that you've dealt with has been the most
difficult has it been with the local
governments the private sector
the veterinarians of the community
animal health workers or the farmers
themselves and bernard if i could start
with you which which of those
[Music]
partners in all of this has been the the
the slowest to make change
that's a difficult question i would say
government because um you know if you
look at the other actors which you have
in the list if an intervention is really
beneficial to them
they will adjust immediately you know
private sector farmers but for
government you know you really need to
put in place policies rules
before
everybody else come to the same table so
i think for me it will be government
okay and lasha how would you uh talk
about this that question
that's tough mark but probably for us
it's the engagement of the farmers
um because to let them understand that
something which is not always linked to
their income
and sometimes opposite that matters for
instance an antimicrobial resistance or
proper use of the veterinary medicine
products proposed waste of uh
by-products etc that could i mean this
process is a slow process and it's more
and more engagement for all the partners
okay and
the same question to you uh vadessa what
uh
part of the partnership has been
difficult for you
he's heard actually
it is from uh
perspective of like because i've seen
this environmentalist because
this
an understanding of uh
health aspect is somewhat is different
from rangeland because it is a
government and
if you are like we see from a
pastoralist point of view different
organizations are there so
and some of them also say government
okay thank you
and we have one question that's come in
uh from
abdel fatha
and
what are your thoughts on selecting for
poultry or livestock that are
genetically
predisposed or
resistant to any of the avian influenzas
or other diseases
and what's work is being done on the
crossbreds uh for that process
i'm not quite sure who who is
best to answer that question if you'd
like to speak up
do we do we have someone who's been
handling uh the selection of poultry and
livestock for genetic and avian
influenza
um we already had a discussion on that
in the chat this is christina
and
i mean uh i'm not speaking for hillary
we are not uh working on on um selecting
breeds uh resistant to avian influenza
we do that kind of work um
feeding and cross-breeding um disease
resistant animals even genetic
engineering um yeah to generate um
disease resistant animals but
yeah
it can work in the lab you still need to
get it to the community so one of the
examples i i brought up was the
gamma kettle from west africa which is
very small but resistant to trypanosoma
infections and the masai herders in east
africa
really didn't like it because it was too
small not considered a real cow so even
though that that cattle breed was
resistance to disease they opted for the
disease
so uh and and we have other examples
where we are trying to crossbreed um
cheap that are resistant to uh worm
infections uh and it's definitely a good
bio a medical or genetical approach to
disease control and but it's others
working on avian influenza
reading thanks i hope that helps a bit
yeah thank you
uh it looks like a good question has
come up for um
looks like bernard or
vadessa and the question is zoonotic
infections form the bulk of re-emerging
or emerging disease burden that could
benefit the attention of one health and
management
what is being done to actually manage
the introductions from wildlife
so i think uh that might be closer to uh
bedessa
yeah
i'm in my perspective view
because that's why
we put a participatory rangeland
management bring to this
one health approach today this rain land
management
if we have an integrated integrator
management plan
these all things should be at minimized
to absorb this as the issue of health
else for management actually the
wildfire so now we are like if we take
the pastoral area there is a wildlife
there is a climate climate change
there is a land health
uh so this is under the umbrella of
environment so we are doing
this project by compiling together
having a
strong
integrated management plan to be
integrated into one health
um and i've noticed that
last year would like to speak on that as
well as we think through
uh the question on this crossover from
uh from wildlife elijah please thank you
mark so actually one of the uh materials
that we also developed is regarding
how to build the cattle farm and that
also includes how to select the place a
lot of about biosecurity measures
and all the threats that come to the
farm from the wildlife from the imported
animals and other sources but and that's
i believe is part of the answer as well
how to separate or how to protect the
livestock and therefore humans later
okay we're going to squeeze in one last
question and um
um
anyone can pop in on this answer okay
what is the one thing that we could do
today that would improve or motivate
buy-in from one health around the world
is it
you know the livestock the livestock
owners the funding the people were
involved or is it the markets that we
need to put pressure on how how would
you guys um
discuss this topic
who would like to go first how about
um bernard you've been quick on the
answers today
oh well yeah that's that's really a big
question so
i would
i would say i think if we get a stronger
consumer demand on on on
healthy and
you know healthy landscapes and healthy
food
i think they can drive much more than
just you know a supply side of things
so i think the demand can really shape
how more healthy value chains can be
developed
and i'm hoping that would really
also force the private sector to come
into in into into the picture much more
okay well i should let's build on that
private sector notion what how would you
uh answer the question
well actually mark now we're on the way
of developing the market like
the food safety and quality standard on
the primary production level
and i agree with
bernard that yes indeed
consumers awareness demand from the
consumers needs to be there but also we
should support the the production and
primary production processing level to
to meet up the standards the standards
that sets the government but also
especially the market-led standards that
motivates the the processors to to move
on
thank you sir
well
we've heard from our panelists now and i
want to give time for a wrap up here
from uh christine yost she's the global
health security initiative a senior
livestock advisor with usaid's bureau of
humanitarian assistance
she provides technical support on saving
lives and livelihoods of livestock
keepers and fisher folk she lies with
global
humanitarian and resilience
communities on issues regarding food
security and food systems animal health
emerging and transparent diseases
she has over 30 years of the experience
and working in over 40 countries and so
we'd like to use her expertise to
put a final note on today's webinar
christine please thank you mark and
thank you to all the speakers today i've
really learned a lot i want to highlight
a few things i liked how
the speakers were kind of organized in
research policy and then really looking
at practice from christina we learned
about the importance of preparing
detecting and responding
in one health approaches preparing in
terms of
particularly focusing on localization
detection and both both the importance
of the biomedical and the social
sciences
you know it's important to remember that
disease isn't simply a biological
problem it's a socio-economic problem
requiring one health approaches and then
responding in terms of coordination and
targeting at all levels one of our main
lessons from responding to the ebola
outbreak in west africa that ended in
2016 was the need for improved
coordination and it's a lesson we are
learning again in the covid19 pandemic
from bernard we were introduced to the
one health regional center for africa
with its focusing on policy and scaling
and it was good
to
to hear bernard recognize the challenge
of conceptualizing
one health um and the need to integrate
that into scaling approaches um both at
uh the in in public efforts such as the
national one health platforms as well as
graduate programs and community outreach
and then from lasha and badassa we we
really had a nice look into
examples of putting one health into
practice both in
market systems as well as in terms of
linking rangeland health to one health
what came out from the discussion and
the contribution of the participants for
me is that one health is not just an
approach to research it's also an
approach to practice policy capacity
building that recognizes and supports
the inextricable linkages between
environmental animal and human health
as livestock experts we need to
continually challenge ourselves to think
about and address what livestock
research and development means for the
health and well-being of people and the
environments in which we live and how
often we should be asking ourselves are
we collaborating with the ecological and
human health communities
thanks mark
thank you i'm gonna hand back over to
michael now and he'll take walk us
through our ending points thank you all
for attending hi thanks a lot mark and
thanks a lot christy and that was really
interesting uh with that it would just
be really great to hear uh from
everybody if they can put into the chat
just uh what were your main messages
uh
that came out of the uh that came out of
the webinar
it'd be really good to to see what
people want
uh and as we're as people are as you're
typing that in please type it in and uh
and we'll take a look at what you have i
we will be having another webinar
hopefully before the end of the year
we'll let you know uh all the the
presentation and the uh the recording we
will send out to everybody as well
uh so let's see is anybody have any
key comments
uh andres said some something about
where can they find more
reading about one health uh maybe
christina could put some some uh links
there we have a one health page on the
hillary website as well
the german experience program has a
facebook page that will direct you to a
lot of materials there as well and all
to the so to the georgia farmers
association
gfa excellent
okay let's see if there's anything else
uh if not i think we're we've uh come to
the end and perfect timing good job mark
i'd like to really thank everyone behind
the scenes we had
uh madeleine uh madeleine butles from
venture 37 we had tessa martin from
venture 37.
uh murray
uh
from uh hillary we had uh susan and we
have uh jeffrey
uh as well all kind of helping out and
really helping to make this uh this
webinar series go
i'd also like again to thank christina
for really jumping in and fortunately
delia couldn't come today as well uh but
really this was a nice uh conversation
and uh thank you everyone for attending